[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui ces bouges la science donc
de l'édition à 2020 donc ici on se
trouve dans le bâtiment eiffel du campus
de centrale supélec
donc c'est une journée où on invite 200
collégiens sur le campus
donc c'est une journée on propose des
expériences on la remonte des
expériences scientifiques
donc le but c'est de leur sortir du
cadre traditionnel et puis les
intéressés à la science pour qu'ils
essayent de continuer les études il ya
plusieurs stands qui sont proposées aux
collégiens
donc on a des stands de notre
association donc on en croit des
expériences scientifiques
il ya aussi des associations de l'école
avec le club tech donc le club
technologie de l'école donc là derrière
moi il montre le fonctionnement d'une
imprimante 3d
on a aussi le club l'intelligence
artificielle qui montre avec des réseaux
de neurones des petits jeux assez
sympathique
on a le club de véhicules autonomes qui
est un robot qui peut suivre tout seul
une trace au sol donc voilà ils sont
répartis dans des petits groupes ils ont
une petite pause déjeuner où ils peuvent
se reposer et l'après midi et qui
continuent à traverser les expériences
les collégiens et aussi les professeurs
qui les encadrent sont très contents de
la journée donc voilà il découvre en
plus dans les bâtiments plutôt moderne
et neuf donc c'est agréable pour eux ça
leur montre un peu commencé la vie après
la pré liste et donc ils sont collège
mais ça leur montre la vie les études
supérieures ils sont super contents ils
discutent avec des gens avec des
étudiants ça leur change de la routine
de telles missions espérance en béton
c'est une association qui organise aussi
des des séances de tutorat donc trois
fois par semaine on se rend aux ulis
donc une cité juste juste en dessous et
donc on propose aux collégiens ou
lycéens motivés de les aider dans leur
aide aux devoirs
donc on fait de l'aide aux devoirs on
fait aussi des visites de l'école pour
des gens par exemple on a fait visiter
des lycéens guyanais qui ne sont venus
visiter l'école on a des gens ne sont
après pas des élèves en prépa qui va lui
quitté l'école et non contient aussi
bouge la science donc c'est notre
événement phare c'est de la science une
fois par an
[Musique]